I have a very defined version of God in  my life it's very defined and I needed  it to find now that may not be for  everybody and that's cool you know you  call it what you want at the end of the  day what it really is is just love you  know every great abrahamic text talks  about the same [ __ ] like God is love and  so I didn't know how I didn't know what  love was I didn't know what that  actually meant and what it is is it's  it's selfless service for your fellows  that's what love is it's the [ __ ] that  nobody sees it's the quiet service it's  the quiet small work that's really  what's been motivating my life it's the  only reason I can like wake up and have  any respite in my life it's only a  reason I can have any kind of reprieve  from this non-stop monologuing that  happens in my head that will put me in a  shame spiral